-I'm so happy to see you.
Thank you so much for coming.
-Thank you for having me.
Jimmy, are you
my closest friend?
Every time I have
a life milestone,
I'm coming on "Fallon."
-Yeah.
-When I got married,
when I was pregnant.
-Last time you were here.
-Yeah, and I gave birth and I
was like, "Okay, call Jimmy.
We've got to get this --"
-Let's get going.
Yeah, there's another
life moment.
-"I'm going on 'Fallon.'"
-How's baby?
-[ Sighs ]
She's so creamy-dreamy.
She's just --
We call her a Twinkie.
Just filled with breast milk.
She's chunky.
I'm just -- I'm nibbling.
I'm kissing.
-Yes!
-You have a baby
to bite the thighs.
-Yes, that's what you do.
That's why people do it.
-That's right.
You don't get to kiss another
person's baby on the mouth.
That's bizarre.
-Nope.
-And you don't get to bite
other people's baby's thighs.
-Yeah, that's correct.
You don't.
It's the best.
And I got to see
a picture backstage.
And man, oh, man,
congratulations.
I'm so happy for you.
-Thanks. Thank you.
-You -- I also got to see
a photo that you posted
that I think a lot of us can
relate to, a lot of parents.
-Yeah.
-This is working right now.
This is you working during
the pandemic.
-Yep, I go from toilet to the --
-Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. That's you.
-That's my commute from --
-That's your office.
-Yeah, from therapy to work,
I'm toilet to edge of tub.
Door is closed most of the time.
-Yeah, isn't that inter--
That used to be, like,
bath is a place for relaxation.
-That's right.
No, now it is work and --
Internal work and external work.
-Yeah. Exactly, yeah.
Are you figuring out
apartment life
and figuring that all out
with baby?
-Yeah, being a parent
in New York City is crazy.
I'm just up so many stairs.
I'm like, this is --
As long as I have good form,
it's a workout.
Every day, I'm working out.
-You got to make sure your
form is on point.
-I'm tucking the pelvis.
I'm opening the chest.
-Got to work the core.
-Groceries -- I'm like -- I'm
a Sherpa or something.
I'm just carrying bags.
It's a crazy life.
-You know, you don't think about
this stuff when you're doing it.
-No. I'm like, "Aww, baby."
And then I'm like, groceries
is -- This is bananas.
-Yeah.
-This is a trip.
-Yeah. We were talking about --
"Hashtags" earlier was
"MyHighSchoolWasWeird."
And I was just wondering,
did you have any weird moments
in high school
or have a weird high school?
-I mean, like, the weird part --
I went to high school
on Long Island,
to a big public school,
and I went to school
with like 2,500 kids.
That, to me, was what was weird,
was the feeling
of being cattle, I guess.
We had four minutes.
I think that's
a standard thing --
four minutes between classes.
Running -- Like, it was --
Why can't you get the
fifth minute in high school?
You're already filled
with anxiety and self-loathing
and just, like,
running past people.
It was just so --
When people talk about
their high-school experiences
of like,
"Oh, I graduated with
like 20 kids,"
I can't even -- I didn't know --
I knew, you know,
2% of my class.
-That's wild.
-Yeah.
-And were you involved with
any clubs or anything
or teams or --
-I was in student council.
I was a big nerd.
I was in plays
and student council.
And -- ugh! -- I was actually in
an anti-drug club called
The Positive Edge.
-Wow.
-I was on the positive edge
of the drug war or something.
And that really worked,
clearly, for me.
Just banking a big part of
my career on weed.
-What would happen at
Positive Edge meetings?
-We would talk about --
Honestly, we would cut class.
That's what it was.
You did The Positive Edge
to cut class
and go teach fourth and
sixth graders not to do drugs.
And it's lies.
It's lies.
We're telling them,
"Don't do drugs, guys,"
as we're starting
to experiment with drugs.
It was like
the D.A.R.E. program.
Like, did that work?
-Yeah.
-We had, like, a cop come
and tell us how bad drugs were
and some bad guy
is going to sell you drugs.
The truth is that
your friends sell you drugs.
That's who's pushing it.
-That's interesting.
You're not in
an alleyway somewhere.
-I'm a nerd.
-"Hey, come here a second."
And it's like it's
your buddies going -- Yeah.
-It's my friend stealing
his brother's bong
and, like, sneaking it like
a dork in his inner pocket.
It's -- No, it didn't work.
-Well, you have to kind of
channel your inner high school,
because "The Afterparty" --
Which, by the way, well done.
-Incredible. So, it was
created by Chris Miller
and produced by Lord and Miller.
These guys can't miss.
-They really can't.
It's levels of funny and, like,
Easter eggs of fun
and creativity.
-Yeah, it was so good.
The cast is bananas.
-Everyone's funny.
-It's about
a high-school reunion,
and a pop star
who went to the high school
throws an after party,
played by Dave Franco --
cracked me up on set.
And it becomes
a whodunit murder mystery.
But there's two twists is
that it's a multi-genre show.
So, there is a teen movie,
a rom-com,
a psychological thriller.
And the other twist is that
it's, like, a rock-star cast.
This was such a blast to do.
It's, like, comedy athletes
that I got to work with.
-Were you exhausted,
like, working with these guys?
Because they really --
Everyone is really, like,
at the top of their game.
-We were cracking up,
and it was --
You know a little thing or two
about breaking.
I was like...
[ Laughs ]
You know -- Yeah.
-Yeah.
I could not make it
through one scene.
-I was -- I know.
We were really --
-I mean, Tiffany Haddish,
John Early.
-Now that I am a mother,
I'm just a full-on, like,
mom dork, a proud mom.
So, I'm going to read the cast,
because it's incredible.
-I love that you were holding it
in your sleeve the whole time.
-Tricks up my sleeve.
-Wow!
I love that -- You totally could
have pulled that out
from my ear, and I would have
been like, "What?!"
-Listen to this cast.
It's Tiffany Haddish,
Sam Richardson, Dave Franco,
Zoe Chao, Ben Schwartz,
Jamie Demetriou, John Early,
Kelvin Yu, Ike Barinholtz,
Tiya Sircar,
Ayden Mayeri,
and Genevieve Angelson.
It's a rock-star cast.
It's incredible. Incredible.
-It's so well done.
It's worth your time.
It's funny. It's interesting.
I'm so happy for you.
And you have to come with
every milestone of your life.
-I know. I guess when my
daughter is bat mitzvahed.
I mean, that's in
a while, but...
-Yeah. You're open invitation.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ilana Glazer in
"The Afterparty."
Take a look.
-What...are you
doing here, Chelsea?
-What are you doing here?
Wait. Shh. I know.
You're looking for Zoe.
-Yes.
-You're looking for Zoe.
-I need to find her.
Have you seen her?
-I haven't.
Oh, wait. Yes, no, yes, I did.
I did. I saw her, um...
Oh, my God.
Can you hold on one second?
-Yes, yes.
-Hello?
Just kidding.
-Stop it! Where is she?!
-You know what? I'm just...
-No. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Key, key, key right back there.
Zip, zip, zip.
-Ah! It's woman's code.
I can't tell you!
-He unzipped your mouth.
So funny. Ilana Glazer.
The first three episodes of
"The Afterparty"
begin streaming tomorrow
on Apple TV+.